great that you came to berlin today
the outline of his visit about
the situation in europe are very very serious the
greater my joy that i can
welcome you here today you are coming from
latvia canadian troops are making an
important contribution there to defend the alliance territory germans
soldiers stand by
the neighbors then scramble to
secure nato's eastern flank we are
grateful that our transatlantic
allies are making such an important
contribution to security in europe
then russia attacked
ukraine we agree on that marks a
turning point
for europe but also for the
peace order the russian attack
on ukraine is a blatant breach of
international law and the world
we live in is no longer the
same
we are now seeing many attacks on
ukrainian cities and schools
and residential buildings making the citizens
of ukraine suffer from the people in the
war zone  understand all of us  no
what we need now is a
ceasefire and an appeal to the
russian president now and then stop
the bloodshed withdraw the
russian troops it is a
terrible catastrophe for the ukrainian
people but the russian people are also suffering
from this war
we need one now
armistice and that we need an end to
the armed conflict that it
must come to an end i also talked about this
with my
french colleague in the manual macro
and the conversation that took place with the
chinese president
that is clear to everyone that a
military solution to the conflict is involved  it
doesn't make any sense what we need now
is a diplomatic solution and that's what
we're trying to do in close cooperation with
our international partners and we
hope that there will be solutions in the
talks between ukraine and
russia and that we can find a
way out of this situation
helps what we do it our hi  it
is well
known that the award-winning goals by
us are unanimous that we do
not simply
go over to day-to-day business wherever that is possible, especially the
international organizations and
that is why it is a very special sign
that the general assembly of the
united nations is quite  unanimously
condemned russia's action in this matter condemned the war of aggression against
ukraine the
world community will
not accept this action and will
not accept it either that is crucial and
that is what everyone who is now
pushing this war forward must
do until we have not talked here  only
about the war and how we
stand together together to protect the people
in ukraine with the possibilities
we have but also
about the long-term development of
our world and so
climate policy plays a very,
very central role for both of our countries it's au  ch important
and central when it comes to the priorities
of the germans the seven
presidency where canada who
act side by side as like-minded partners what we
would like is that the glass climate
that forgets and packs small is
implemented and we also want to do everything we can to ensure
that the  global
community works together that's why we're pushing the
project at the international climate
club in which countries that are taking
different
steps to reduce co2 emissions and create a
co2-neutral world will continue to work
together despite the
different paths i'm very
grateful that canada is the duo just
but a close alliance partner is so that
we can move these things forward it
's about harmonizing our efforts with this climate
club it also plays a big role
in the question
of co2 pricing that's
why i'm also very grateful
for your co2  pricing initiative this
is a  very, very important proposal
that you presented in glasgow and
we will support it, of
course, the question arises as to how
we can implement our ambitious
climate policy goals,
as a reminder, germany already wants
to be climate-neutral by 2045, that's almost
25 years as
one of the  most successful
industrial countries in the world this is a
big challenge
it's about heating it's about
mobility but it's also about the
industrial processes that make up the
majority of energy consumption
and which we
therefore have to change accordingly
and we agree that  it is important
that we follow this
path by focusing on the expansion of renewable
energies on wind power offshore and
onshore canada does it have other
options with hydropower that we
promote solar energy strengthen our grids
and that we work closely
together on the use of
hydrogen
for  it is important to us that
we initiate close cooperation on this
issue and that is exactly what we have planned to do
together, that we do everything to
ensure that
hydrogen, which we would also
like to obtain from canada, plays a central
role in the economic cooperation of our countries and  we will also keep an eye on
the question of raw materials
because we too are now
concerned with diversifying borea we get the
important raw materials for our
industry and of course it is
also about diversification in the
issues that are important to us when it
now it’s about gas imports to
germany we need more
alternatives good that these can also
be the structure in
which we can build up a hydrogen economy in the long term
that’s what’s
planned in germany that, if i
understand correctly, is also the way
canada is going  very glad we extended our
many encounters to one more
that
started long before i became
federal chancellor and that we
can continue our efforts
for a world that holds together better,
that is socially fairer, but
at the same time that is also
able to build on man-made
climate change  solve and right now it's all
about peace, of course
, the people who
are suffering now and have to
protect them deserve
that thing
count
mr scholz mr trio, from
your point of view, a delivery of combat aircraft from poland to ukraine
now finally already  off the table with the
new one from the usa and mr scholz, germany would in
principle be willing to allow something like that
or do you fear that
germany, for example
by using rammstein, would be drawn too far into the
military conflict
rhein we have
organized support as you know it is about
financial aid  which we have been
on the road for many years  in order to strengthen the
residency of the economy of ukraine
we have now
continued this during the crisis there is a lot of
financial support we have
initiated humanitarian work
we have also provided all kinds
of equipment
and, as you know, individual weapons
about which we have informed you and
otherwise it is so that we have to think very
carefully about what we are doing specifically
and that certainly
does not include combat aircraft
english is
apa
canada and germany are pursuing the
same goals when it comes
to achieving a climate-friendly industry
and both  countries are very, very
ambitious, we are successful
economic nations that also participate intensively in
global trade, and
yet we are very clear that we
also have a task that goes far
beyond ourselves because the
technologies and solutions that we
develop are if they are
globally competitive  And at the same time also
technology solutions that can then later be used in many other
countries around the world
because we have
shown that it is possible and because we
have found out the possibilities that can be
used this applies in particular to the use
of hydrogen because when we
Germany in the shortest possible time I have
already said that we will be CO2-neutral by
2045. If we want to achieve this in the shortest possible
time, then we
will need considerable additional
amounts of electricity that we
generate offshore onshore with solar energy and with our strong electricity grid,
but we will also do so on a large scale
scale hydrogen requires that
part of the fossil resources used today be
replaced this hydrogen
will be produced in germany
but will probably be mainly
imported from other countries and
this is more of a starting point for
a very intensive strategic
cooperation between canada and
germany  and because we understand exactly
that canada is a country that can help
us with the import of hydrogen,
which is then also produced in a climate-friendly
manner in hydrogen in canada, by the way
, this applies not only to
hydrogen but also to many
raw materials that we use every day for our
story  still need every day and of
course it is obvious that
we deal with the question of how we
can solve the medium and short-term problems that
arise when we
want to diversify our energy supply,
which in the transition phase also
uses fossil resources
- that's a task that's just  the easier it is to
manage and the more you have the
long-term perspective at the same
time,
canada and germany are probably among the
most ambitious because as far as the fight
against climate change is concerned, and
therefore such a partnership
is very close to working together on all these
issues  anyway we
will u  ns now first of all to
lay terminals on the north sea coast that will improve our
supply options
and in the long term these
terminals will be used for hydrogen
yes a follow-up question science
assumes that germany could also
get along without russian energy in the short term the economy is
n’t going to pick up on that for the time being  see is
your no to russian energy
imposing a ban on it is that
categorical or do you see under
what circumstances could you
imagine the energy being
reduced to germany beforehand we are
particularly in touch with our partners also
with our transatlantic partners
i.e. canada and  the usa completely agree
that the dependency on fossil
raw material imports in europe is very
different from the dependency of the usa
or canada, for example, the usa is an exporter of
gas and oil, for example, that cannot be said for
europe as a whole and therefore
these are the things that can be done  n
also different and everyone knows
that we have short-term challenges
that have to be overcome if, for
example,
economic cooperation
in this area does not work anymore, that economic relationships in this area no longer
work as they did for many years
and decades and
there are  many technical questions to be solved
that cannot be replaced with mathematical
model
calculations at least all practitioners know this very
well nevertheless we devote ourselves to this
topic and what may be
good and reassuring information for you
not only recently i
discussed with everything in december  we have
to prepare for the situation
that it's going to be
complicated and we've started with that
, but we also know exactly how
complicated it is